so thanks everyone for coming I hope
you're not frozen to death yet but so
this talk is sort of inspired by
something that many people would think
it's just a marketing slogan and when
you look at when you look at F sharp
website the official observe dot org
homepage it says F sharp is a major open
source cross-platform functional first
programming language and then it says
how great it is for for people and for
companies I did have to shorten it a
little bit but I think what's
interesting is this functional first
phrase because everybody knows what
functional programming languages are
well you can go on Wikipedia and read
what functional programming languages
are so why did why is why ahrefs are
people using some weird phrase like
functional first and I think it does
actually say something interesting about
how the language works and this talk is
is tried trying to unpack that a little
bit mostly through fairly practical
examples of how absorb looks so if you
if you think about functions and and
functional most function what is what is
a function well a function from A to B
is an object and such that for every a
in uppercase a there is unique little
unique unique value F of a in a set B so
this is what the mathematicians will
tell you this is a definition of a
function and when people talk about
functional programming they actually
often refer to mathematics mathematical
concepts and the idea that you can write
programs by constructing something like
a mathematical function but it turns out
there's there's
yet another meaning of the word function
and I think there's there something like
50 years anniversary of the Bauhaus
school which is where a lot of the
modernist architecture sort of comes
from or where it where it got its
inspiration and in design or in
architecture a function is the purpose
for which something is designed or for
which something exists so the the game
of this of this talk is let's try to
pretend that functional programming
isn't treating function as a
mathematical object but it's actually
talking about this function and I think
this is actually in in a way sort of
closer to how absorb and absorb program
programmers and absorb community thinks
about function so it's maybe this is
actually a more useful analogy or more
useful parallel for programming than the
mathematical function so one of the one
of the sort of key slogans of modernist
architecture was form follows function
and in in architecture the idea is that
if you're designing a building if you
sort of design it according to what it
was meant for then the the form of the
function will actually embody sort of
the the essence of what it's for and one
of the sort of common complaints about
modernist architecture is that it's all
just boring boxes and that's slightly
actually going against against this
principle because the the idea of the
slogan was that if you really understand
the function you'll you'll design
something very individual because every
every sort of building has somewhat
different function so that's my sort of
background and that's that's sort of the
inspiration for this talk
look at some examples of functional
programming in F sharp and try to
interpret it not as function as a
mathematical object but as function as
as a purpose and I'll have a look at
three different areas or three different
sort of categories of examples one is
transformations and a lot of code in
well in any programming language really
the purpose of it is to transform some
value into a new value using a series of
transformations lots of business
processing does there's lots of event
processing does this it's just a very
very common pattern and how does F sharp
deal with it so how many people in the
room have seen some F sharp already
quite quite a lot of you so the first
example is going to be totally trivial
it's it's pretty much the thing that
everybody in F service all the time and
I have a list of values the only
interesting thing about this is going to
be my political jokes so this is a list
which has a conversion rate between
pound and dollar and what I can it sort
of for every date I've got a value
so there's 7th January 2016 this is the
number and I can do various
transformations to my list so I can get
pairwise combinations which will give me
the previous and the current value
forever so you sort of have a list of
dates and you'll get a list of pairs of
dates and then I can do something like a
med function where I take the time or
the date before and then the now day
and I'm going to just print before and
I'll get the date of that and formatted
the string so if I run this it's kind of
tiny in there but that's alright it
gives me a list of formatted date and
you can do lots of other interesting
transformations like filter the data and
one interesting thing you can find is
find some days where the drop the rate
the rate dropped by quite a lot so for
example if I do now exchange rate -
that's the other way round isn't it well
the nice thing about f-sharp is that I
can try this in F sharp interactive
really quickly and see if I did it the
right way or not so is there a date
where the exchange rate dropped by 0.1
or more yes there is it was 23rd June
2016 than the night the Brits voted for
brexit all right so that's one example
of transformations not breaks it but the
list operations but the same principle
works for many many other things so this
is another example but what I'm using
here is a library called Deedle and
that's a library for working with data
frames so rather than just having like a
list of things I now have this data
table and if I scroll up a little bit
well you can see even from the far that
this looks like a table so I've loaded
data on Titan it's a famous data set
with Titanic passengers and they all
have names they have gender age they
have how much they paid and I also know
whether they survived or not
and this is library that lets you do
various operations over the entire table
of the data so for example I can take
data and I can use something like well
let's first do this so you can sort of
ask the library to calculate average of
every column that's numeric and this
gives me for example the average age
which was 29 and other information and I
can follow exactly the same pattern as
before so there's a set of functions for
transforming data frames so I can for
example transfer filter rows and look at
only rows where the sex column is male
and I'll find that the average age of
male passengers was thirty point seven
if I look at female passengers the
average age was twenty seven point nine
so it's just an example where you can
actually you're actually using pretty
much exactly the same pattern previously
for lists now for entire data frames and
there's a lot more you can do with data
frames so this is a code snippet that
actually does thus even more so what it
does is that it will reorganize or
restructure the the data frame so that
sex is not just one column but it's part
of an index so the thing on the left
before this arrow is an index and it's
sort of defining this the structure of
the rows and now I restructured my data
so that I can easily find what are the
male and female passengers
and you can do various things about with
indices for example you can apply some
aggregation operation over everything
that has the same value as the index so
if I run this I'm actually going to get
a new data table which has all the same
columns as before but now my index is
just male and female and I've averaged
sort of aggregated everything over male
and female passengers so there's sort of
two points here one is if you're working
with data tables have a look at Deedle
which is a nice excerpt library for
doing this the other point is that the
sort of same mechanism using the pipe
operator actually works for many many
different things in the language and I
think the sort of analogy with
architecture is that there's also sort
of many patterns in architecture that
have been repeatedly used over and over
that let you do quite different things
so this is a picture from my home
country from slean which is where the
bat a shoe factory was was sort of
established I think at the end of 19th
century and in the beginning of the 20th
century they sort of built lot of lot of
different buildings but they're they're
actually using the same style for both
of those sort of large office buildings
or factories and for the houses that
they built for the workers so if you're
if you're there you'll see that there's
this sort of consistency in style across
many many different things and I think
the pipe in F sharp is actually kind of
similar idea where you just get
consistency across lots of different
things so I showed you two examples with
data but pipe is actually a lot more
useful than that so this is yet another
example
how do I actually zoom well I can zoom
but that's right
so this is a little playground fun 3d
dotnet that I built together with filter
Alfred for his back then eight-year-old
son who is learning F sharp as you do
when you're eight and this is using this
is using pipe but rather than for
transforming data at this using pipe for
doing for transformations on some visual
objects or some shapes so I can take
this cube and change the color that's
the orange I run it and I get orange
cube or I can turn this from cube into I
think we have cylinder let's see yeah I
really don't know how to zoom now the
other the other thing is so aside from
aside from this I can also move things
so if I say move then this is where I
have to get my coordinates right but I
think I can move the cylinder up so
instead I'm going to move it down what I
want it and the only other operator that
I have here is this dollar and this is a
custom operator that I defined so it
doesn't really exist every elsewhere in
F sharp I did need one more one more
thing in this example I can create cone
and compose it with cylinder so now we
have a tower and I do have nicer version
of my tower with more colors and here
the roof is actually a bit bigger and I
think this might be the moment where the
lack of zooming will hurt us because
I do have a castle as well but castle
might just be too big now if it's fits
all right but the key point here is
rather than transforming lists or data
tables I'm now transforming shapes but
the code is actually still using pretty
much the same sort of construction block
so I say give me a cone change the color
rescale it give me a cylinder change the
color rescale it move it and there's a
little bit more but in the end you just
you just end up saying built four towers
and built four walls so I think that the
sort of interesting point here that is
that the pipe operator is something that
lets you do quite a lot of different
things using the same sort of expression
and and it's because the purpose the
sort of function is always the same it's
composing transformations and the way
I've served does it is sort of similar
to what what architects do you so one of
the one of the key phrases with the
modernist movement was the elimination
of ornament and in in buildings it meant
that you weren't weren't supposed to be
doing things like that but instead you
just built sort of straight straight
concrete walls and straight glass
windows and they'd F sharp you you sort
of achieve similar thing by elimination
of keywords so F sure doesn't really
have like a sort of special language
extension for doing for doing list
processing it doesn't have something
like link but it does have a general
purpose mechanism that lets you express
the same style it's not it's not
entirely true because I've served us
actually have sort of link like
extensions but they're still based on
some general more reusable principle
it's kind of amazing that this if
there's if there's one thing from
f-sharp that really got into lots of
other programming languages
it's the pipe operator which I think the
definition is something like eleven
characters so that's the that's the last
thing lasting legacy of F sharp eleven
characters so that was that was one
example of sort of a design principle or
design mechanism that exists in F sharp
that's useful for a variety of things
and surf's one particular purpose
another example that I think fits this
idea very well as well as type providers
so type providers our language mechanism
that's that's designed for to let you
sort of navigate through some
information or data source and extract
extract some data from it so let's have
a look at two examples and close my
Titanic
close my lists so I'll start with a
completely trivial example this is the
type provider that lets you access data
about countries and the way it works or
the way the way type providers work in
general is that there's sort of compiler
extensions or compiler plugins in a way
where the types they give you get
generated on the fly while you're typing
in your editor or while the compilation
happens so what happens here is that the
type provider actually looks at the
World Bank which is among other things
as an organization that has large data
base
information about various countries and
it gives me all the countries that it
knows about well it gives me countries
and then also various other aggregations
and lots of different things so I can
look at Portugal for example and if I
look at indicators this will this will
give me a list of all the data data
series that actually the World Bank
collects about all the countries that it
knows so I did increase the font a bit
too much you can't really see quite what
the what the entire name of the of the
field is but if we look at say carbon
emissions then if I run it I get back a
data series well let's let's turn it
into a list I get back a data series
where for every year I have the total
carbon emissions of Portugal and we can
draw this as a line so this is a line
chart of carbon emissions of Portugal
and I can do a little bit more so if I
want to compare let's say compare
Portugal and let's do China South China
China so I'm still using the type
provider to navigate through my data set
and find some interesting data points I
get my chart yet no not yet
I'm probably real am i missing semicolon
I think it shouldn't be shouldn't be
strictly necessary here so I could add a
semicolon here but I think a missing
internet rather than semicolon so let me
try well first let me try doing this
again and maybe the internet will come
back that's not the right way to get rid
of it
do I need to pin it all right let's see
that done
maybe it just doesn't like China I'm
going to try United States instead oh it
doesn't like United States even more
well then it's really because I'm
missing Internet yeah that's alright I
did show you at least one example of
this although I'm going to try something
else
I do I do have one more example which I
want to show you and that one does also
require internet so it might be better
if it started working nice BEC so let's
try this again
and there we are so this is Portugal
carbon emissions compared to the u.s. I
think Portugal is on the bottom there
and this isn't very interesting because
we are looking at the absolute values
but fortunately the data source also has
data in metric tons per capita so this
is per person and this is where this is
where we actually learn more interesting
things sorry
just sort of based on the shape that I
showed before this is Portugal and this
is the u.s. so this was one example of
accessing data but the main point here
is that this is again a mechanism that
works for lots of different things
so aside from aside from looking at the
World Bank
there's tie providers for many other
data sources and one that's quite
interesting
the type provider that lets you parse
any json files so i do have an example
where so that's this long URL as a URL
over of a web service that gives you
better forecast and what i'm doing here
is that i'm defining a new type called
weather which is a type for any data
that is returned in the same format as
this example so i scroll down here so
what happens now is that I can say
weather dot load and give this a URL of
the service I'm just going to use
exactly the same one as before and when
I when I run it it loads data from that
service and I can say W dot and I get a
type that's generated based on the
sample JSON file that the service
returns so I get back some JSON and I
can do dot on this it's it's a static
type it's not like it's doing some some
magic it's just a sort of type that's
generated by the type provider and I can
see that there's a list of things which
happens to be the the dates for the
weather forecast and I can do for day in
this list return let's say what is their
temperature during the day
let's do a bar chart for example so
here's the here's the battery forecast
for the next for the next few days I
think it actually starts at the bottom
the main point is again I'm just using a
general-purpose language mechanism here
that lets me easily access data and in
the previous example we were doing dot
to navigate through some big database of
country indicators here I'm just using
dot to navigate through things in a JSON
file and one of the sort of motivations
for the modernist architecture or one of
the slogans was that it tries to convey
the message of simplicity using basic
geometric forums or simple materials and
in a way I think that the idea of dot
and accessing something is really sort
of an implementation of this idea in the
programming world so you really just say
dot to navigate through some object or
through some some data space and it's
one simple construct designed for for
doing that that lets you do it across a
wide range of of data sources and again
you don't really need sort of special
very like domain-specific construct for
accessing data from let's say SQL or XML
if you have a if you have a mechanism
that can use the same simple structure
to access data from lots of lots of
different sources so unlike some of the
other languages F sharp doesn't have
support for XML literals and I think
nobody really Minds because
people just started using Jason the nice
thing is that the constructs that absorb
has can actually be used with with both
both XML Jason and many many other other
kinds of data sorry this was the example
of the Jason type provider where you're
using dot to navigate through data and
you do need some other language
constructs like looping if if there's if
there's a list but fundamentally you're
still doing it with dot and I think one
of the one of the sort of fun thing
about modern modern architect what
honest architecture was that they very
often tried to see how far can you go
with a given material so once people
started using reinforced concrete they
were sort of creating all these all
these crazy structures so this is this
is a building in Prague but there's one
I saw I think this is in Sao Paulo it's
a building that really holds just on
these four sort of pillars at the at the
ends and it's just a sort of huge huge
gallery that all just works based on
that based on that one material and in
programming languages people I think
often try to do the same so my next
example close all these charts is a
project I've been working on in the alan
turing institute that tries to use dot
for data exploration growing well beyond
what people do with type providers
normally so I have a sample data set
which is I'll show you what it looks
like
I think this might work maybe I did
something wrong or maybe I need internet
again yeah I probably do need internet
again
alright this was this was actually my
mistake because I loaded the entire
table which is quite big so I don't need
it well I do need to internet as well
but I also need a fast browser so what
this looks like is that it's a it's a
data table with various information
about all the people ever winning and
the Olympic medal in Summer Olympics you
have columns with things like what was
the year
what's the discipline what was the medal
day God what's the team and so on and
the interesting thing is that this this
tool actually uses the tie provider
mechanism and uses dot for doing a lot
more than just picking picking data from
from your data source it gives you a
little scripting environment where you
can aggregate the data as well so if I
want to look who's the athlete with the
largest number of Olympic medals overall
I can use dot to group the data and the
type provider generates not just the
sort of available data but also the
available operations so I can group the
data by athlete and then it says what
are the aggregations that you want to
add and in my case well I'm going to
concatenate the values of team which
will give me sort of all the other
countries that the athlete ever competed
for it's typically going to be just one
and I'm also going to get some the
number of gold medals and then I'm done
with picking my aggregations so I'm
going to just do dot then and dot then
isn't isn't really like a special
language construct it's just another
member of this object and then I'm going
to say paging take the top ten
well I need to source first so let's
sort by the number of gold medals
descending take the top ten and now I do
need to use one more language construct
which is let to sourced a save my result
and I'm going to create a table with the
results and I think that should work
let's see I think it's not complaining
correctly maybe it is ignoring my type
errors because I don't trust my software
but I think now okay one more thing I
need to get my data and now all errors
are gone and I'm going to get a table
with at least with the largest number of
gold medals in the Olympic Games overall
so this sample code this little
scripting environment isn't really using
F sharp as the scripting language it's
it's has its own little language that's
pretty much inspired by F sharp and
there's it's using the same type
provider mechanism that also also works
in F sharp it is actually written in F
sharp and you can find it online it's
using the fable project which lets you
translate F sharp to JavaScript so
everything I was doing actually runs in
a in a browser but the the key point is
that something as simple as tie
providers where the only idea is when
you type dot invoke a little bit of code
that generates the members it's
something that you can you can take
quite far and this is basically
re-implementing a little SQL like
language where you can construct queries
just by using dot so if dot is the
concrete then type providers are like
the reinforced concrete of programming
languages so that was that was the
second example so we talked about
transformations and pipe data access and
dot and my last example is going to be
computation expressions and this is
something that when people think about F
sharp coming from programming languages
like Haskell they'll just say oh this is
just a monad and that's sort of
mathematically that it's not quite right
but it's a sort of worthwhile statement
to think about but I think when when you
look at the observed feature I want to
talk about from the mathematical
perspective it doesn't really tell you
very many useful things about how it was
designed and why it works the way it
works so let's have a let's have a look
at F sharp computation expressions which
is one of the sort of more advanced
fancy F sharp features but thinking more
about what's the what's the purpose of
it and why it works the way it works so
the purpose of observed computation
expressions is to give an alternative
meaning to an ordinary computation so
what that means what that what that
really means is that if you have some
bit of F sharp code and you want to make
it asynchronous or you won't want to
make it produce multiple results you can
you can use the computation expression
to sort of change somewhat what it does
I think my architectural analogy here is
that very often the context really
matters so this is a sort of fairly
fairly ugly part of Prague but if you
take the same kind of structure and put
it in a different context it suddenly
becomes becomes looking very different
in F sharp so I've got an example here
which is a bit of code written in sort
of normal synchronous way that creates a
web client download some URL and returns
the length of the URL of the page they
also handles exceptions and if it fails
then it returns none the nice thing is
that if I want to make it asynchronous
I'm just going to wrap it in this async
curly bracket block so I'll switch back
and forth so that you can see the
differences I'll wrap it in the async
block and then and let bank rather than
ordinary let right there so this is this
is a construct that has been an F sharp
for probably 12 years now or something
like that and it inspired the the C
sharp async construct but the sort of
nice thing here is that in F sharp is
actually sort of the purpose is more
general it's sort of reinterpreting the
meaning of a computation and it's not
just making it asynchronous because the
the async curly brackets you can
actually create other things that work
the same way so I wanted to show you one
quick example of using asynchronous
computations and for that I'll have to
jump here
and I've got one more example this one
is also also using fable so that's why
I'm running it from the command line I'm
going to run yarn start to start my
project so what I'm doing here is that I
have a little I've sharp script that I'm
going to be translating to JavaScript
using fable and I'll I'm going to be
using the sort of fable the typical
fable setup where you have a command
line built running in the background
that monitors the changes to your file
and when you save your file it will
recompile it and start serving a webpage
with the new version so did this did
this finish I think it did if we go to
localhost:8080 here's my little demo and
here's the source code for my demo this
is not the source code for my demo this
is a wrong wrong folder this is the
source code for my demo so right now I
my file just says show section 1 and
then turn the circle green if we change
it to red and save it this will
recompile in the background reload and
now it's red so if you're if you're
doing anything web related have a look
at fable because it lets you write F
sharp run it in the browser and this
sort of work flow where it reloads
automatically it's just super nice so
it's a great great way of just learning
F sharp as well and so one example of
what I want to do is do a little bit of
asynchronous programming for the user
interface and one thing I always found
extremely annoying when when doing UI
programming
that you can't just say set the color to
red then sleep for one second and change
the color to some other color and a
normal programming or in sort of
WinForms or WPF you can't really do that
because you can't block the main threat
in browser it's the same thing if you
just want to sleep for one second you
have to do it using a timer and your
code ends up being a terrible mess so
the nice thing we can do with async and
F sharp is that I can actually say async
sleep one second and then let's see if I
know how traffic lights work you
probably can't go from red to green that
would be bad so let's do you know that
would be all right right
I don't want to go from green straight
to red I want to give orange first so
let's see what my traffic light does
it's red green orange and then it stops
so we should do this in a loop and the
nice thing here is that I can actually
just say well true do this and then I'll
end up with a traffic light that runs
forever in loop waiting one second
between the changes and I think this is
probably safe so the way the way this
works behind the scenes is that the
async dot sleep operation does actually
create a timer and when the timer sort
of after one second when it takes and
will resume the computation because
that's one thing you can do with
asynchronous computations and it doesn't
the the nice thing about sort of how the
code is structured is that this is
something that makes makes obvious sense
because you just have code that changes
color weights changes color weights
changes color weights you didn't have to
completely restructure the code just
because it ends up being the case that
you
block threats in JavaScript so you sort
of have normal code that you would wrote
you would write everywhere if you were
doing something that actually sleeps but
you can reinterpret the code so that the
sleeping happens without blocking and
you can still use all your normal
favorite language constructs inside here
so I can say for color in red green
orange do change the color and sleep and
now I have well now I have the same
thing as I had before but in a lot more
cleaner way and one other change I can
do here to make it more fun is that
rather than just waiting one second
I can wait until I click on the button
so now I have a traffic light where I
can click so this is a this is a sort of
nice example of UI programming and I
think using async firfer doing these
sort of UI
tasks where what you're doing is
encoding some sort of state machine is a
really powerful pattern so that's one
point the other point is that if you if
you sort of unsee the async curly
brackets then it really looks like
ordinary F sharp code that iterates over
two loops and changes some colors and by
adding the the async curly brackets we
sort of don't lose any of the normal
intuition about what the code does
so you still can understand it and
there's only one sort of extra extra
trick which is that rather than all this
happening synchronously it happens
asynchronously but that's sort of a
technical detail you don't really have
to worry
about too much and when sort of people
coming from the Haskell background say
oh this is just a monad that's that's
sort of technically technically that's
that's true here but if you're using it
what you care about is your sort of
intuition about how the language
constructs work and that's that's
something that absorb does very
differently because an f-sharp you have
four loops you have while loops and you
can still use them inside this construct
so that was my example of asynchronous
computations and the sort of design
reference here is one of the sort of
modernist ideas was use flexible
material and design with the material in
mind so something like computation
expressions is a lot more sophisticated
language construct than say the pipe or
dot unless you do do quite a lot of
advanced things and there's some cases
where it's appropriate some cases where
it's not so this is this is another
picture from from Sao Paulo with sort of
fancy fancy Park with with concrete
reinforced concrete sort of buildings in
there or constructions and it makes
perfect sense in that context because it
provides shading from light when it's
just very hot another another example of
shading is this this place so this is a
Louvre Museum that was built in Abu
Dhabi and the roof for it was actually
designed using F sharp so the person
build it well not building the turns out
that model that architecture is really
complicated business
and there's so many people involved but
the person who was sort of implement
creating the concrete design proposal
wrote some F sharp scripts to generate
the patterns of the of the sort of metal
things that that hold the roof and the
the design motivation was that you want
to have it sort of more dense in some
areas and to let less light through and
less dense in some other areas to let
sort of more more light through it so I
think they're sort of less dense less
dense area that where it provides sort
of some sunlight through it but it's
it's definitely something where they
sort of thought about what's going to be
the material that's available and what
can they what can they do with it and
here they ended up with this really
really fancy roof designed using observe
and I think that the focus on the
material is really something that
becomes really useful for thinking about
programming as well so one of the things
that I often find in F sharp is that if
you're if you're designing some
obstructions it should be either really
really easy or well if you have if you
have if you have language like observe
that sort of enforces you or forces you
to do things in in certain ways then
using the right abstract abstraction is
either really really easy or almost
impossible and the point is that it sort
of leads you towards the easy easy bit
and it makes your life really hard if
you're trying to do something that
doesn't quite work and I think one
really nice example here is sort of
taking the asynchronous programming
ideas from just asynchronous
computations that produce one result to
asynchronous computations that generate
sort of sequences of bad
and I'm actually going to start with an
example first because I do have enough
time to show this so I've got I'm going
to delete this part and I've got one
more example so what what this sample
does it defines two types I have I have
some JSON files and these types are
basically just matching the JSON files
and I'm iterating over all days in a
year and I have one file for every day I
read the file and convert the result to
this record and I'm going to find the
exchange rate for four pounds $2 I'm
going to display this so and then I'm
sleeping sleeping 100 milliseconds so
you can really see I'm too worried about
currency exchange rates so breaks it so
if I say that this now sort of replace
replace how the how the pound value has
been changing over time but what I want
to show here is another another
computation expression that is available
in or there's there's library for doing
it in F sharp which is combining two
different things it's combining
asynchronous programming where you don't
have where you don't have to block if
you're waiting and it's combining that
with computations where you can produce
multiple values so
what I want to do is to sort of
restructure the code so that the the
reading of these values is separate from
the code that actually does the UI part
and I can do this really nicely using
this async construct which is kind of
like a thing except that in addition to
doing all the things I can do in a thing
I can also say yield and now I have to
fix the rest of my code
and learn how to type no that's what I
want so what I've done what I've done
there is that get prices is now a
function that returns an asynchronous
sequence and a synchronous sequence can
still have some asynchronous operations
in there but it also generates a stream
of values she's going to move the
sleeping here so that I do actually wait
so it can block asynchronously or it can
do asynchronous i/o but it can generate
multiple values so here I'm generating a
stream stream of values and I can
iterate over that
inside another asynchronous sequence and
then rather than starting my a thing
I'll just start my asynchronous sequence
and I did do dot value and the first
function so I don't have to do it in the
second one all right so if we run this
again it does nothing because I did
break something all right
I don't immediately see what's wrong
here so I'm not going to waste time on
trying to figure that out and let's just
see if I can fix it by cheating because
I do have a working version here
yeah maybe not maybe sorry oh yeah I did
change it to clicking well I think I
think there's there's probably something
else wrong
but the the key point here is that I'm
using the same language construct which
was the computation expression syntax
which previously I was just using for
doing computations that are asynchronous
and produced one value but I can also
use it for doing computations that are
asynchronous and produce multiple values
and the way the computations work behind
the scenes is that they're doing what
what the reactive programming people
would call pool based so it only
generates the next value when you ask
for it and that's really nice because it
lets you do things like for loops where
you can you can block inside the for
loop if you have event like observable
you can't really iterate over observable
in a for loop and block inside the body
because what would you do if the
observable started generating more
values while you're blocking so that's
kind of a an abstraction that doesn't
really let you use these use these
constructs and doing that would be
almost impossible you'd have to come up
with some crazy hacks and here I've got
an abstraction where I can actually
nicely and really easily construct
things like for loops because it just
says pull the next value from the data
source asynchronously process it and
then pull the next one sorry this is one
of the one of the sort of more
interesting abstractions that are
available for in F sharp and if you're
doing any sort of asynchronous
concurrent processing have a look at AC
Karina's sequences because you might
find them nice all right so to wrap up I
think when you look at modernism in
architecture people say it's sort of
associated with trying to understand
what's the thing was the function using
new materials keeping things simple by
eliminating ornaments and that's really
those ideas are really something that
you can find very very useful in
programming and I think F sharp in many
ways sort of tries to embody those ideas
so function composition lets you
eliminate lots of keywords type
providers give gifts sort of extra power
to very simple idea of dot and
computation expressions let you
reinterpret the existing material and
and use it for many other new things so
I think what I what I talked about was
functional programming except that
rather than interpreting function as the
mathematical object I was trying to
interpret it as the purpose for which
things were designed and I think this is
really useful perspective but sadly
functional programming is taken already
so I'm just going to be calling it
functional first programming I said
thank you
[Applause]